bien mes chers collègues
il est 9h03 donc je vous commence que
nous je propose que nous commençons sans
plus attendre
la matinée est en chargée pour les uns
et les autres avec les réunions de
groupe en particulier
donc rapporteurs Patrick Chaze et le
week-end vous saluez vous tous chers
collègues membre de cette commission
spéciale en votre nom j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir vos collier Metz président
de la recommande le présente plus de la
même manière qu'on ne présente plus lors
de la redière présidente de l'ARCEP et
Marie-Laure Denis présidente de la CNIL
mesdames les présidents monsieur le
Président notre commission spéciale a
été constituée afin d'examiner le projet
loi visant à sécuriser régulier l'espace
numérique la variété des missions que
vous remplissez suffit à souligner
l'ampleur de ce texte et plus
profondément l'orientation qui est la
sienne et que je crois nous approuvons
tous qui est de mettre enfin en place
une régulation efficace dans mon
numérique qui ne doit pas être laissé à
l'état de Far West
sans rentrer dans le détail du texte je
vais dire quelques mots sur chacune de
vos autorités dans le projet de loi
monsieur vestre LARCOM est avec le temps
et de multiples projets et propositions
de loi devenues le grand régulateur des
contenus numériques à tel point que
votre désignation comme coordinateur
pour les services numériques en
application de l'article 49 du règlement
des services numériques n'a souffert
d'aucune contestation
le projet de loi redéfinit également
votre mission en matière de contrôle de
l'accès des sites à caractère
pornographiques et vous savez que c'est
un sujet très suivi par de nombreux
membres de la commission spéciale avec
trois rapports sur 4 du rapport de la
délégation au droit des femmes si on
industrie pornographique c'est très à
niglion Alexandra borchio fontaine
Rossignol sans oublier bien sûr Marie
Mercier à l'origine de l'article 23 de
la loi du 30 juillet 2020 qui n'a jamais
été réellement appliquée je n'oublie pas
l'article 4 qui est en votre compétence
au numérique pour la mise en oeuvre des
mesures restrictives au niveau européen
de quoi largement occuper le collège et
les services je réitère bien entendu
notre souhait que vos moyens soient à
l'avenir au niveau de vos missions
madame de La Rodière larcep se voit
attribuer le rôle de gendarme de
l'informatique en nuages on dit Cloud et
ce sera au coeur du suivi de
l'application des dispositions relatives
à la régulation à l'interopérabilité à
la portabilité des services
d'informatique en nuage ainsi que des
dispositions relatives au service
d'intermédiation des données
vous pouvez donc être deux sanctions et
de saisines sont ainsi renforcées des
mesures essentielles pour mieux affirmer
notre souveraineté numérique dans les
prochaines décennies cela soulève bien
sûr de redoutable question technique et
juridique et nous serons heureux de
bénéficier de votre pédagogie en la
matière
enfin madame Denis la CNIL est forcément
également placé au coeur des enjeux
numérique et ce n'est pas un hasard si
d'ailleurs deux membres du Sénat de
notre de votre collège sont également
membres de la commission spéciale notre
rapporteur Loïc Hervé et Sylvie Robert
que je salue également
car l'or noir du numérique ce sont les
données personnelles mais aussi les
données de nos administrations et nos
entreprises et ces données doivent faire
l'objet d'une protection toute
particulière encore plus si je puis dire
à l'heure de l'intelligence artificielle
pour lequel vous travaillez je le sais
il nous faut donc à chaque fois je pense
notamment au contrôle de l'âge équilibré
entre les aspirations légitimes de
protection des mineurs et la collecte de
données vous serez ainsi chargé avec
l'arcom de l'élaboration du référentiel
prévu à l'article 2 mais vous aurez
également intervenir sur le déploiement
du filtre anti-arnaque prévu à l'article
l'acné l' étant désigné comme autorité
garante du caractère justifié
proportionné des mesures prises dans le
cadre de ce dispositif ce n'est pas un
petit rôle je vous propose donc
l'organisation suivante je vais demander
à chacun d'entre vous d'exposer les
enjeux propres à son autorité dans le
projet de loi les éventuels points de
vigilance
je vous demande de vous limiter à cette
huit minutes si vous le voulez bien pour
pouvoir passer la parole au rapporteur
en commençant par Loïc Hervé puis
Patrick chaise avant bien entendu de
laisser nos collègues membres de la
commission spéciale s'exprimer je vous
précise que notre réunion fait l'objet
d'une captation en direct sur le site du
Sénat monsieur Mestre je vous cède la
parole
merci madame la Présidente merci de
votre invitation de votre propos
d'accueil je suis très heureux de
retrouver ce matin les membres de la
commission spéciale et je veux souligner
d'emblée vous l'avez fait madame la
Présidente combien l'autorité est
sensible la confiance que le Parlement
lui manifeste depuis que je préside
cette autorité je crois que j'en suis à
mon dixième projet de loi je pense que
d'ici la fin de mon mandat elles exclu
que j'en connaisse encore quelques-uns
donc c'est une autorité grâce à cette
confiance qui aura été très
singulièrement transformée le projet loi
qui nous réunit bien évidemment
important notamment pour la mise en
oeuvre du règlement européen pour les
services numériques qui va changer la
donne en Europe c'est la première fois
qu'on a un texte de niveau européen qui
s'attache à réguler les grands acteurs
du numérique je vais je vais revenir
au préalable je voudrais souligner
peut-être trois points d'abord la table
ronde que vous avez organisée l'illustre
très bien la nécessité
l'importance de l'interrégulation
aujourd'hui parce que les acteurs que
nous avons en face de nous pour les
autorités qui nous rassemble ce matin
sont en grande partie les mêmes et
avec Marie-laure Denis d'une part lors
de la Rosière mais je pourrais citer
d'autres autorités également nous avons
eu à cœur depuis le début de nos mandats
respectifs de tisser des liens étroits
des liens de confiance et de
collaboration
quotidienne qui sont tout à fait tout à
fait essentiels et leur cèpe comme la
CNIL sont pour nous des interlocuteurs
très important dans la mise en oeuvre de
notre action la deuxième chose deuxième
point de vigilance pour nous c'est bien
évidemment la cohérence des taxes
nationaux et des textes européens la
régulation que nous déployons a de plus
en plus une dimension européenne l'arcom
joue un rôle central au sein du groupe
des régulateurs européens les regards en
étant dialogue avec la commission sur
beaucoup de taxes directives services mé
visuel la mise en oeuvre du DSA le
règlement européen l'impAt sur lequel
vous avez travaillé prochainement le ce
texte essentiel sur la liberté des
médias en Europe et donc l'articulation
des textes nationaux et européens sont
bien évidemment très importants et puis
le troisième point je vous l'ai
souligner sur lequel on doit toujours
être très attentif puisque notre
autorité intervient vous le savez dans
un champ fondamental qui est celui d'une
liberté publique essentielle la liberté
de communication c'est toujours veiller
à l'équilibre entre les mesures de
protection des publics en l'occurrence
des plus des plus jeunes et puis la
protection
d'une liberté essentielle donc la
liberté de communication donc c'est une
balance à laquelle on est toujours
extrêmement attentif de trouver le bon
équilibre entre ces deux préoccupations
à l'égard du texte qui vous est soumis
qui est soumis au Parlement aujourd'hui
par par le gouvernement donc l'arcom a
rendu un avis un avis favorable je
rappelle que ce texte vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente comporte trois
types de données d'abord première série
de dispositions qui attrait à la
protection des mineurs en ligne à
l'égard
en particulier des sites pornographiques
c'est un texte qui vise à répondre le
sénateur merci pour le souligner je
pense dans son intervention à répondre
aux difficultés enfin euphémisme que
j'utilise auquel on est confronté depuis
la loi de 2020 sur les violences
conjugales
en raison de ce que je qualifie
manoeuvre dilatoire
de la part des sites qui sont en phase
de nous qui qui incarnent parfaitement
l'industrie l'industrie pornographique
qui depuis l'adoption de ce texte de
2020 n'ont à aucun moment pris la
moindre initiative pour essayer de se
conforter sans conformer à ce texte et
on multipliait tous les outils toutes
les initiatives juridiques que permet un
état de droit pour faire obstacle à la
mise en oeuvre à la mise en œuvre de ce
de ce texte
s'est attaché pied à pied à déployer la
mise en oeuvre de ce texte par les
procédures de mise en demeure que permet
que permet ce texte qui ont bien
évidemment été chacune d'entre elles
contestée
Haddock puis ensuite par une saisine du
tribunal judiciaire de Paris comme le
permet le texte pour demander le blocage
de ces de ces sites nous sommes
maintenant dans l'attente d'une décision
du tribunal qui est attendu pour le 7
juillet prochain on verra ce qu'il en
est nous formons le feu le feu que notre
demande de blocage soit suivie en ayant
la conviction que tant que cette
décision n'aura pas été rendu les choses
ne bougeront pas donc de ce point de vue
là on accueille favorablement le texte
qui vous est proposé aujourd'hui
qui vise à permettre à l'autorité de
disposer elle-même d'un pouvoir de de
blocage et d'une capacité de demander le
déréférencesment de ces sites sur les
moteurs de recherche s'ils ne se
conforment pas naturellement au
disposition du Code pénal en matière de
protection des mineurs
nous formons néanmoins de façon
conjointe avec l'acnil avec laquelle
nous avons beaucoup échangé ces derniers
jours
peut-être une proposition conjointe de
rédaction de taxes on en a parlé hier
soir avec le rapporteur Loïc RV d'une
meilleure articulation rédactionnelle
entre l'article 1 du texte et l'article
des finalités un tout petit peu un tout
petit peu différentes et d'autre part
d'instaurer avant la mise en œuvre d'une
procédure coercitive engagée sur le
fondement de l'atteinte à la vie privée
une procédure de consultation formelle
de la CNIL par leur COM qui nous paraît
de bonne aloi puisque le texte
a une double finalité
protection des mineurs mais aussi une
dimension de protection de la vie privée
et donc dans dans la logique que j'ai
évoquée d'une bonne articulation une
bonne interagulation
ce mécanisme de consultation formelle de
la CNIL nous semblerait un élément de
sécurité supplémentaire donc ça c'est
une observation que je voulais faire
d'essayer d'améliorer la rédaction du
texte avec une meilleure articulation de
l'article 1 et 2
je souligne que ce texte ne nous met
néanmoins pas à l'abri de difficultés
contentieuses il faut pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt
quand le texte sera adopté nous
n'échapperons très vraisemblablement pas
à des procédures et notamment un moment
ou un autre une question
à une QPC
il faut pas oublier que beaucoup des
sites dont nous parlons sont des sites
qui sont localisés à l'étranger ce qui
bien évidemment complexifie le sujet
mais en tout cas l'arcom sous les
réserves que je viens d'exprimer donne
un avis favorable à ce texte la deuxième
dimension du texte à très
aux chaînes étrangères
qui sont c'est une proposition qui vient
de ce que nous avons vécu avec les
événements tragiques qui se déroulent en
Ukraine on a été dès le début du conflit
confronté à la question de la suspension
de chaîne diffusant de la propagande en
l'occurrence de la propagande russe
qui a donné lieu vous le savez des
décisions de sanctions
adoptée par la Commission européenne
c'est des sanctions d'application
immédiate directe l'arcom a participé
bien évidemment du fait de ces
compétences à la mise en œuvre de ces de
ces sanctions et la prononcer elle-même
d'ailleurs des mesures de blocage
au titre de ses propres compétences mais
on a été amené à observer des cas de
contournement dans l'univers d'Internet
auquel le cadre juridique actuel
n'apportait pas de réponse satisfaisante
je pense notamment à la reprise du
signal de la chaîne RT pourtant bloquer
sur un site qui était le site Odyssey et
on a vu à ce moment là les difficultés
j'allais dire les lacunes pour
assurer le blocage effectif de cette
diffusion donc le texte vise précisément
renforcer
l'efficacité de la mise en oeuvre des
mesures de sanctions par l'Union
européenne à l'encontre de chaînes
étrangères donc en application l'article
215 du traité
c'est un texte qui renforce les pouvoirs
du régulateur on lui donnant un pouvoir
d'injonction et de retrait auprès des
services qui diffuseraient ou
hébergerait des contenus de médias
eux-mêmes sous sanction et en cas
d'inction donc sous 72 heures la
possibilité de demander le blocage et le
des référencements du site contrefaisant
au fournisseurs d'accès et moteur de
recherche
dans notre esprit on disait hier soir
devant le
rapporteur monsieur Monsieur Hervé
l'objectif tel qu'on le perçoit et bien
bien évidemment de s'attaquer aux
mesures de contournement d'une décision
adoptée par par l'Union et non d'aller
sur un contrôle contenu par contenu site
internet par site internet donc on est
bien dans dans cette approche là
aussi comme pour les articles précédents
il faut avoir bien un bien dans tête
la difficulté qu'on aura probablement à
mettre en oeuvre les sanctions
financières
à l'égard d'éditeur ou d'hébergeur qui
sont établis aux quatre coins de la
planète et donc le recouvrement des
sanctions
recouvrement financier comme on dit à la
Cour des comptes ne sera pas
nécessairement l'exercice le plus le
plus simple mais en tout cas on s'y
attachera
dernière disposition qui est bien
évidemment très importante
c'est la désignation du DSC donc qui est
un des éléments de la gouvernance du
nouveau règlement européen sur les
services numériques dont l'acronyme
en français d'outrement et le DSA
c'est un texte très important pour nous
parce que d'une certaine façon il vient
parachever la réforme de l'institution
et la création de l'arcom on nous
désignant donc comme autorité de
coordination nationale en France pour la
mise en oeuvre de ce de ce texte je
voulais souligner devant devant votre
commission que pour nous il y a une
dimension fondamentale dans ce texte
c'est le C de DSC ces dimensions de
coordination mission de coordination que
nous porterons en liaison étroite avec
la CNIL avec laquelle nous avons
largement anticipé et travailler sur le
texte ces derniers mois pour bien
identifier
les textes du règlement qui intéressent
très directement la CNIL Marie-Laure
Denis je pense il reviendra dans son
dans son intervention mais également
au-delà de la CNIL la direction générale
de la concurrence puisque des
dispositions du texte vous le savez vise
les questions de contrefaçon des
questions qui touchent au droit de la
consommation et donc dans notre fonction
de DSC nous aurons à coeur et nous
organisons d'ores et déjà la
coordination avec les autres autorités
nationales qui sont concernées par ce
texte pour assurer sa bonne application
on se réjouit également dans le texte
que
l'articulation entre larcome et le
pérenne qui se servit à compétence
nationale qui a été créée il y a
quelques années pour mettre à
disposition
de l'ensemble des administrations
françaises et des autorités
administratives qui en ont besoin des
compétences techniques rares et des
expertises rares on est heureux que le
texte
mette en lumière cette collaboration qui
pour nous sera bien évidemment précieuse
pour la mise en oeuvre de ce de ce
règlement européen
deux autres remarques et j'en aurai
terminé pour souligner que la mise en
oeuvre de ce texte va nécessiter une
étroite collaboration avec la Commission
européenne
puisque le règlement prévoit un niveau
d'obligation différents en fonction de
la taille des plateformes donc les plus
grandes plateformes les plus importantes
donc
les Facebook les Twitter les TikTok les
Google enfin tous ces grands grands
acteurs seront sous un contrôle plus
direct de la Commission européenne en
liaison avec les autorités nationales
qui auront été désignés par chaque pays
donc l'arcom pour la pour la France donc
ça suppose que ce conseil qui sera
organisé autour de la Commission
européenne fonctionne de manière fluide
et nous sommes là aussi déjà
en anticipation dans l'organisation de
ce mouvement se tient prochainement des
réunions à Bruxelles je participerai
moi-même pour bien organiser ces
circuits et de la même façon nous aurons
une articulation étroite à avoir avec
nos homologues étrangers je pense
notamment aux homologues irlandais qui
hébergent nombre de plateformes nous le
savons autour de cette table
j'étais en Irlande il y a très peu de
temps pour précisément organiser ce flux
de relation et enfin Madame la
Présidente je ne peux qu'être très
sensible aux vœux que vous avez exprimé
du renforcement des moyens de l'autorité
nous avions obtenu dans le cadre de la
loi de finances pour 20 3 la possibilité
de créer quelques emplois
supplémentaires nous souhaitons que la
loi de finances pour 2024 permettent de
compléter ce mouvement pour doter notre
direction des plateformes puisque nous
avons créé il y a deux ans et demi
maintenant une direction des plateformes
en ligne qui est en charge tout le volet
de la régulation des acteurs du
numérique puissent trouver le bon etiage
et les bons profils puisque c'est une
régulation d'un nouveau type qui fait
appel à des techniques nouvelles et donc
c'est important qu'on puisse être
renforcé pour pour mener à bien ces
missions voilà donc un avis favorable
sur le taxe ça va être quelques petites
observations notamment pour le texte sur
la protection des mineurs sur laquelle
je pense qu'on peut peut-être optimiser
un peu la rédaction merci de votre
attention
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
je passe la parole à
le président de la recette merci madame
la Présidente messieurs les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
madame la Présidente de l'acnil monsieur
le Président de la recom
je suis très heureuse d'être aujourd'hui
parmi vous pour vous donner la vie de la
recette sur le texte de loi nous sommes
concernés par le titre 3 du texte qui
vise à renforcer la confiance et la
concurrence dans l'économie de la donnée
et je dirais aussi renforcer
l'innovation dans le domaine du
numérique
un mot sur la recette vous savez que la
recette a été créé au moment de
l'ouverture du marché des télécoms en 97
dans l'objectif de développer la
concurrence sur un marché de favoriser
l'innovation et nous avons aussi au fil
des ans prix des compétences de
définition des normes permettant
l'interopérabilité et la portabilité
dans le domaine des réseaux des
télécommunications nous sommes aussi le
garant de la neutralité de l'internet
qui favorise l'innovation et qui
favorise aussi la liberté d'expression
mais qui avait été
prix règlement de la neutralité Internet
a été pris par la Commission européenne
justement pour garantir en fait à
l'ensemble des acteurs d'avoir accès à
Internet de façon
sans discrimination et aux utilisateurs
d'accéder à l'ensemble des contenus qui
existent sur Internet
et nous avons travaillé aussi sur
l'ouverture des marchés numériques
notamment en amont du digital marketact
avait rendu un rapport
concernant les terminaux comme maillon
faible de la neutralité d'Internet en
disant que les terminaux numériques les
smartphones étaient des lieux en fait de
où les gens étaient prisonniers et c'est
un maillon faible de ce qui existe en
matière de neutralité sur les réseaux
d'ailleurs le Sénat avait à l'époque que
la Commission a fait économique du Sénat
madame la Présidente Sophie prima déposé
un texte pour en amont du digital
marketing pour des verrouiller ce marché
numérique donc ce que cette introduction
simplement pour vous dire que dans notre
culture nous avons une culture
d'ouverture des écosystèmes numériques
nous sommes une autorité pro-innovation
et procurrence
et donc nous sommes un régulateur
économique sur le champ des télécoms qui
a élargi progressivement son action sur
le champ du numérique
donc nous accueillons avec beaucoup
d'intérêt les nouvelles compétences qui
s'inscrivent en continuité de nos
réflexions que ça soit sur
l'interopérabilité et la portabilité des
services Cloud où ça soit sur
l'autorité en charge de la régulation de
ce nouveau type d'acteurs qui sont les
prestations de services d'intermédiation
de données j'y reviendrai l'objectif du
texte c'est d'une part sur le marché du
cloud de le déverrouiller parce qu'il
est aujourd'hui fortement concentré
autour de quelques acteurs qui sont des
grands acteurs américains il y a peu de
français et cette situation
se renforce au profit en fait des grands
acteurs par des pratiques
qui sont des pratiques
je sais pas si je dois les qualifier
d'anticoncurentiel parce que c'est à
l'ADL c'est de le faire mais qui
verrouille en fait les les utilisateurs
du Cloud sur sur des plateformes
et ça c'est l'objectif de l'article que
je vous dise pas de baisser l'article 6
pour lequel l'ARCEP sera pas compétente
mais qui est confiée à la DGCCRF et
confie en fait le texte confiait à la
recette les la définition des
spécifications et des modalités
permettant l'interrogariabilité et la
portabilité des services Cloud donc il y
a à la fois des freins commerciaux je
dirais des freins de contractuel qui
empêche une migration facile des
utilisateurs des services Cloud mais il
y a aussi des freins purement techniques
en fait qui empêche aujourd'hui de
facilement migrer d'un fournisseur de
services Cloud à un autre fournisseur de
service cloud et le texte confie à la
recette la définition
de modalités de spécifications pour
faciliter la migration des clients d'un
service cloud un autre service cloud les
services Cloud il y a plusieurs types de
services Cloud différents sans rentrer
dans la technique selon le type de
service cloud que ça soit des
infrastructures sur des plateformes ou
ceux des logiciels on devra adresser en
fait le sujet de façon spécifique
sur chacun de types de services le texte
prévoit que il est la mise en place
d'applications
d'interface d'application pour permettre
le transfert il permet pour un certain
type de service qui sont les services
Cloud d'infrastructures une équivalence
fonctionnelle je vais pas rentrer dans
la spécification de ce que c'est qu'une
équivalence fonctionnelle mais
simplement vous dire que ces prévisions
sont cohérent par rapport
à la position du Conseil
au niveau européen dans le cadre des
discussions actuellement en trilogue
pour le règlement européen du Data Act
vous savez que on légifère là sur les
articles concernant le Cloud en amont de
l'adoption définitive du règlement
d'attaque ou plutôt vous allez légiférer
sur ce sujet en amont du dataque donc
une des vigilances répartières sur les
articles qui concernent
l'interopérabilité et la portabilité du
service de cloud et de vérifier à la
cohérence
des discussions actuellement cours avec
la au niveau européen
et peut-être de ne pas
trop détailler les choses pour permettre
de faire évoluer la régulation en
fonction de ce qui sera décidé Infiné
sur le Data acte et donc l'ARCEP trouve
que les rédactions actuelles proposées
et les définitions actuelles proposées
permettent cette évolution et donc sont
bienvenus
le deuxième
la deuxième partie sur lequel nous
sommes concernés par le texte de loi
concerne l'application du
Data govenance acte qui a été adopté en
2022 au niveau européen et qui nécessite
de désigner une autorité indépendante
notamment pour la régulation des
prestataires de services
d'intermédiation de données
c'est ce sont des entités en fait qui
vont permettre l'échange de données sur
un marché sur un secteur en mettant en
place une plateforme technique mais
aussi une plateforme contractuelle pour
assurer des échanges de données de en
toute confiance entre les acteurs d'un
en général d'un secteur type si je
prends un exemple et
l'opérateur rebois aujourd'hui donc qui
est une filiale d'Aéroport de Paris
un projet de développer ce type de
plateforme d'échange de données en
situation de confiance avec l'ensemble
de ces clients de l'Opéra de l'aéroport
de Paris pour permettre en fait une
amélioration du service soit rendu aux
passager soit rendu aux différentes
entreprises
opérant sur le sur l'aéroport et donc il
ils ont l'objectif de créer une
entreprise qui sera après sa terre de
service d'intermédiation de données
entre les différents utilisateurs de
l'aéroport de des aéroports
gérés par Aéroport de Paris
sur ce sur ce
sur cette partie du texte il est prévu
une coopération avec la CNIL qui est
détaillée et qui est trois mécanismes de
coopération sont prévus à mécanisme
général
qui prévoit que l'ARCEP saisisse l'acnil
avant toute décision des pratiques des
prestataires de services
d'intermédiation de données de nature à
soulever des questions liées à la
protection des données personnelles un
mécanisme spécifique lié à la
labellisation et à la et aux
réclamations éventuelle concernant les
prestataires de services
d'intermédiation de données
et puis un mécanisme spécifique
concernant les procédures de sanction la
rédaction actuelle du texte de ce
mécanisme de coopération entre l'ARCEP
et la CNIL nous paraît correspondre aux
besoins en fait des changes que nous
avons avec la CNIL sachant que le texte
le règlement européen du Data
gouvernensakt prévoit que les
dispositions concernant les prestataires
de services d'intermédiation de données
se font naturellement sans préjudice
de celles concernant le règlement des le
rgpd le règlement général des données
personnelles d'autres mécanismes
d'articulation
sont prévues au niveau du texte européen
plutôt le texte européen prévoit que
l'ensemble en fait des autorités
pouvaient être concernées par un effet
des prestataires de services
intermédiation de données sur un marché
exerce toujours leur rôle et donc on
peut imaginer aussi qu'on soit amené à
saisir l'autorité de la concurrence ou
l'Agence Nationale de Sécurité des
Systèmes d'Informations
sur certaines pratiques des prestataires
de services d'intermédiation de données
donc
ça nous amènera naturellement à
poursuivre les coopérations que nous
avons avec les autres autorités
indépendantes comme comme rocolivier
Mestre l'a dit en introduction c'est pas
une pratique nouvelle on a l'habitude de
le faire la recette saisie régulièrement
l'Autorité de la concurrence
notamment sur les analyses de marché que
nous avons sur le marché des télécoms et
l'Autorité de la concurrence nous saisit
aussi quand elle a des avis à rendre ou
des décisions à prendre concernant le
marché des télécommunications nous avons
un pôle commun avec l'arcom pour
travailler sur
des sujets d'intérêt commun notamment
les enjeux environnementaux du numérique
et je dirais qu'il fonctionne qui
fonctionne bien et qui nous permet de
porter ensemble
des travaux sur ces enjeux et donc nous
veillerons naturellement à cette
coopération peut-être le dernier point
si vous me le permettez je voudrais
aussi attirer l'attention que on sera
bien évidemment très vigilant dans notre
mise en oeuvre de
de
ces deux enfin excusez-moi dans notre
mise en oeuvre de l'interrobabilité et
la portabilité des services Cloud des
enjeux et des évolutions du texte
européen parce que ça peut être une
préoccupation qui de savoir s'il faut
légiférer maintenant s'il faut attendre
le règlement intérêt européen l'intérêt
de légiférer maintenant c'est que nous
puissions monter en compétence
rencontrer les acteurs comprendre le le
système c'est un enjeu techniquement
compliqué l'interopérabilité des
services Cloud et la portabilité des
services Cloud et donc l'anticipation en
fait du règlement européen peut donner à
la France en fait
une avance en matière de compétence sur
ces sur ces sujets nous allons avoir des
gens à recruter pour le faire on a aussi
des gens en interne qu'on va mobiliser
dès maintenant sur ce sur ce sujet mais
il y a un travail à faire auprès des
acteurs il y a une concertation à faire
il y a énormément de travail en avant de
prendre des décisions de spécifications
et de modalité en fait de
l'interopérabilité si je prends un
exemple pour la nouvelle compétence de
la distribution de la presse on a mis un
an un an et demi avant de prendre les
premières décisions majeures sur ce
secteur là et c'est un sujet pour moi
qui est sensible d'un point de vue
économique compliqué d'un point de vue
économique mais moins compliqué d'un
point technique donc c'est important de
se dire que si on
légifère maintenant sur l'interviewé
service de cloud on peut vraiment gagner
en compétences et être hyper efficace
plus rapidement
que dans d'autres pays européens ça sera
un atout pour la France
vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'avec ce
texte on anticipe les sujets que vous
avez évoqué le Data axe chers collègues
est encore en cours de discussion donc
on est finalement à la croisée des des
chemins vous nous avez mis en garde
justement sur ne pas trop préciser le
texte qui nous met un peu dans le
baraque quand même je dois dire le
législateur français parce que nous
avons notre mot à dire nous considérons
que nous avons notre mot à dire
et nous avons bien noté cette décalage
en fait temporel dans l'adoption
dérèglement européen merci madame la
Présidente je te donne la parole
maintenant à Marie-Laure Denis pour la
Cnil
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie d'avoir
sollicité la CNIL pour cette table ronde
Charlie d'examiner le projet de loi
visant à sécuriser à réguler l'espace
numérique et qui traduit notamment je
crois le souci de votre commission
spéciale de veiller aussi à la bonne
articulation entre les autorités
administratives indépendantes
représentées
ici pour la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositions à adopté un avis le 20
avril
ça marche pas faut mettre plus près
peut-être comme ça vous m'entendrez
mieux d'accord dans un avis adopté le 20
avril dernier la CNIL c'est prononcé sur
les dispositions de ce texte en lien
avec la protection des données à
caractère personnel alors avant de
revenir sur les principaux points de cet
avis voudraient juste faire trois
remarques d'ordre général
la première c'est que ces nouvelles
dispositions de la loi s'appliqueront
sans préjudice de celles qui sont fixées
par le règlement général sur la
protection des données
comme d'ailleurs la rappeler lors de la
redière à cet égard en cas de conflit
entre ces dispositions et le droit de
l'Union en matière de protection des
données à caractère personnel les
dispositions ce sont les discussions
pertinentes en matière de données
personnelles qui prévalent et il
reviendra à la CNIL de veiller à leur
pleine effectivement le deuxième point
c'est qu'on constate une multiplication
des réglementations qui régissent le
numérique tant du fait des nombreux
textes européens adoptés ou en cours
d'adoption comme vous venez de le
souligner madame la Présidente que de
nouvelles réglementations nationales et
ces régimes prévoient
l'intervention d'un nombre croissant de
régulateur dans l'espace numérique alors
si la pénétration croissante
naturellement des technologies
numériques dans toutes les activités
humaines est évidentes
l'inflation normative et la multiplicité
des textes comporte deux risques
potentiellement tout d'abord celui de la
complexité juridique et donc de
l'insécurité juridique dans
l'articulation de ces textes
et ensuite celui d'une régulation
potentiellement moins cohérente ou moins
efficace de l'espace numérique c'est la
raison pour laquelle des mécanismes de
coordination entre les régulateurs sont
prévus nous y sommes tous prêts
notamment la CNIL et donc je me permets
vraiment d'atterrer votre attention sur
ces enjeux d'articulation et de
coordination qui me paraissent
essentielles
le troisième la troisième remarque
générale c'est que l'acnil partage les
préoccupations du gouvernement et son
objectif de sécuriser l'espace numérique
et si emploie au quotidien au travers de
son action en matière de cybersécurité
et aussi en promovant des actions
d'éducation au numérique
néanmoins certaines des mesures
proposées par le projet de loi soulève
des questions importantes en matière de
protection des libertés fondamentales
des internautes dont le respect à la
protection de la vie privée et nous
appelons donc le Parlement à poursuivre
cette réflexion sur le juste équilibre
nécessaire entre sécurité et liberté
alors c'est précisions étant fait je
souhaite m'attarder sur quelques
dispositions en particulier
tout d'abord s'agissant des dispositions
de vérification de l'âge sur Internet
l'acteur type premier l'article 2
notamment du projet de loi la CNIL
réaffirme son soutien à l'objectif
poursuivi de protection
de la jeunesse les systèmes de contrôle
de l'âge présente des enjeux importants
en matière de protection des données
personnelles et la CNIL a émis plusieurs
recommandations
à ce sujet le texte prévoit que la CNIL
sera consulté par l'arcome sur le projet
de référentiel qui fixera les exigences
techniques
permettant d'empêcher les mineurs
d'avoir accès à des contenus
pornographiques en pratique nous
travaillons déjà la main dans la main
sur ce sujet avec l'arcom pour qu'on ne
puisse pas opposer la protection des
mineurs et la protection des données
personnelles dans son avis le collège de
la CNIL très bien représenté dans notre
commission spéciale
a appelé à préciser l'articulation entre
les différentes mesures susceptibles
d'être prises que recolivier mastre a
évoqué
par ailleurs dès lors que nous
constatons au quotidien le besoin d'un
dialogue continue sur ces sujets très
techniques entre l'arcome et la CNIL il
serait pertinent là aussi comme reconnu
bien mettre la souligné d'introduire un
mécanisme permettant formellement à
l'arcome de saisir la CNIL pour avis
dans le cas d'une procédure de mise en
demeure ou de sanctions d'un opérateur
de site pornographiques naturellement
quand il y a des enjeux de
protection de vie privée
alors ensuite l'article 5 du projet de
loi prévoit de créer une peine de
bannissement numérique infligée aux
personnes condamnées pour diverses
formes de harcèlement en ligne qui leur
interdirait d'accéder à leur compte sur
la plateforme en cause et donc créer de
nouveaux
je profite donc de cette table ronde
pour vous faire part de mes
interrogations sur les solutions
concrètes qui pourraient être mises en
oeuvre afin notamment d'empêcher la
création de nouveau compte par la
personne condamnée en tout état de cause
les mesures pour bloquer les
contexistants et empêcher la création de
nouveaux comptes qui ne sont pas
précisés dans le projet de loi devront
être proportionnés à l'objectif
poursuivi
ces dispositions ne devraient pas
conduire les réseaux sociaux à collecter
des données supplémentaires ou à mettre
en oeuvre des traitements intrusifs pour
l'ensemble de leurs utilisateurs alors
que ces mesures ne concerneront ou ne
s'adresseront finalement qu'à un nombre
limité de ceci
en outre je m'interroge sur la
pertinence d'un blocage qui reposerait
sur l'adresse IP dans la mesure où il
pourrait être facilement contourné par
exemple avec un VPN et que cela
porterait atteinte aux libertés de
toutes les personnes vivant dans le
foyer concerné
en ce qui concerne maintenant le filtre
national de cybersécurité à destination
du grand public c'est l'article 6 la
CNIL approuve le souhait du gouvernement
de renforcer la protection des
internautes contre les risques cyber via
l'affichage d'un message dans leur
navigateur lorsqu'il accède un site
comportant des risques là aussi il est
crucial que l'objectif légitime de
cybersécurité ne conduisent pas en
pratique à une restriction abusive des
libertés de communication et
d'expression à cet égard je note avec
satisfaction que des garanties ont été
apportées et qu’un contrôle indépendant
de la mise en oeuvre du filtrage sera
confiée à un membre de la CNIL et ayant
toutefois l'esprit ce que vous parliez
de moyens madame la Présidente de
reprises que le nombre potentiel de
sites cyber malveillants serait je parle
aux conditionnel de l'ordre de 300 000
par an le contrôle de ces sites
constituera donc un défi considérable
qui implique des moyens adéquat
concrètement l'acné les susceptible de
recevoir des notifications concernant
peut-être 1000 adresses
mail par jour donc faut quand même voir
un peu ce dont on parle et pas
simplement l'acné évidemment l'autorité
administrative qui est chargée
des pouvoirs des compétences prévues par
le projet de loi sa légion des modalités
techniques de déploiement de ce filtre
la CNIL comme elle l'a indiqué dans son
avis et favorable à ce que le filtrage
soit réalisé au sein du navigateur
internet donc sous la responsabilité de
l'internaute
préservante ainsi sa liberté de
communication et que l'activation du
dispositif au niveau des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet les FAI et des systèmes
de résolution des noms de domaine DNS
soient réservés aux cas les plus graves
par ailleurs s'agissant de la régulation
des services d'intermédiation de données
sur les articles 11 et 12 notamment
instauré par le DGA le projet de loi
désigne l'ARCEP pour superviser ses
nouveaux acteurs la CNIL souligne que si
certains de ces acteurs traitent des
données industrielles et très peu de
données personnelles une partie d'entre
eux ont pour activité principale de
commercialiser un accès à des bases de
données personnelles pour ces acteurs le
DGA et le rgpd s'appliqueront
parallèlement et le DGA prévoit qu'en
cas de contrariété le rgpd Prévot
en outre les règles du DGA sont en
partie des règles qui sont décalées ou
précisées du règlement général sur la
protection des données il y a donc un
risque de complexité et d'insécurité
juridique que l'ARCEP et la CNIL devront
parer en travaillant ensemble
la Cnil doit pouvoir notamment jouer
pleinement son rôle dans la
qualification des acteurs et des données
qui traitent ces acteurs afin que même
et la recette puissent déterminer les
règles s'appliquant à eux
l'acné la formule certaines propositions
dans son avis nous proposons que le
collègue de la CNIL propose que la loi
soit complétée pour prévoir une
transmission systématique à la CNIL des
notifications que ces prestataires
feront à larceps pour déclarer leur
activité cela permettrait à la CNIL de
rendre un avis pour indiquer à l'acteur
et à la recette si le rgpd s'applique ou
non en parallèle du DGA et dans quelle
mesure
cela améliorerait la sécurité juridique
et nourrirait le dialogue entre les
régulateurs dans le même esprit une
consultation
systématique et préalable de chacune des
deux autorités arceps et CNIL avant tout
adoption d'un texte de droit souple par
l'un ou l'autre des deux régulateurs me
paraît aussi nécessaire et puis je pense
qu'il y a une modification
rédactionnelle qui serait utile
d'apporter au petit 2 de l'article 13
qui évoque sur des sujets précis
la consultation de la CNIL par la
recette mais en mettant un cas échéant
dont j'ai un peu du mal à comprendre
ce à quoi il se rapporte et que je
proposerai volontiers de supprimer
enfin je veux conclure sur les
compétences confiées à la CNIL dans le
cadre du DGA et du DSA cela concerne
l'altruisme des données la publicité en
ligne et la protection des mineurs
j'approuve les choix du gouvernement
dans la mesure où d'une part l'altruisme
des données reste à construire et
présentera des enjeux en matière de
protection des personnes et ou d'autre
part la publicité en ligne et la
protection des mineurs
pour ces sujets là en tout cas le DSA
précise des règles qui sont déjà
présentes dans le rgpd on regarde la
diversité des acteurs qui devront mettre
en musique le DSA je ne peux pour
conclure qu'un système nouveau sur la
nécessité d'une coopération étroite
entre les autorités compétentes l'arcom
bien sûr
la DGCCRF et nous-mêmes qui existent
déjà de fait pour là encore assurer une
régulation cohérente et garantir une
sécurité juridique des acteurs concernés
je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente je vais
passer maintenant la parole à Loïc Hervé
pour une première série de questions
relatives à notre texte merci merci
madame la présidente madame le Président
de monsieur le Président d'abord une
question d'ordre général le Sénat a
adopté hier après-midi une proposition
de loi relative à la reconnaissance
biométrique qui prévoit un panachage
des collèges permettant par exemple au
présent d'une autorité d'être membre de
droite du collège d'une autre autorité
c'est déjà je crois ce qui existe dans
la prison de la CNIL avec la CADA chez
vous est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut
développer est-ce que c'est le gage
d'une meilleure coopération entre les
différentes autorités administratives
indépendantes que vous représentez ce
matin
vous avez évoqué de manière très
complète le texte de loi qui qui a des
conséquences sur la vie de vos
différentes autorités administratives
indépendantes
est-ce qu'il y a dans ce texte à vos
yeux des lacunes
des domaines qui ne sont pas couverts et
qui mériteraient de l'être en tout cas
l'échelle de ce texte qui pourrait
alimenter le travail parlementaire de
cette commission spéciale pour nourrir
encore
le travail qui est fait monsieur le
Président
de LARCOM on a évoqué hier dans une
audition rapporteur à laquelle
évidemment les membres de la commission
était combinés certains d'ailleurs
étaient présents je pense à leur
entreignol on a on a évoqué cette
question hier mais je pense que c'est
important que vous le fassiez à nouveau
devant les collègues de la commission
spéciale sous ce format d'audition
plénière à propos du référentiel c'est
un le législateur va
vous confier cette mission de rédaction
du référentiel ça peut apparaître comme
étant une question technique
à bien des égards ça ne l'est pas et
j'aimerais que dans les membres de la
commission vous pouvez venir plus avant
sur les questions de planning les
questions des jeux d'ores et déjà de
technologie que vous envisagez de
préconiser afin qu'on puisse mieux
connaître à la fois et vous l'avez déjà
évoqué votre polymère bien évidemment à
la fois les les
enjeux que ça que ça recouvre aussi des
difficultés que ça peut que ça peut
contenir
c'est à c'est un référentiel qui va être
important parce que il va faire
jurisprudence quand il s'agira aussi
d'imaginer et c'est la crainte
d'ailleurs dans sa forme d'acteurs
d'aller sur d'autres d'autres secteurs
de l'Internet qui conviendraient ou
qu'il conviendra
de réguler j'en viens à votre pouvoir de
d'injonction administrative qui est
créée par l'article 2
comment est-ce que vous le concevez ce
pouvoir
donc d'injonction administrative sur
l'accès des sites pornographiques aux
mineurs on a bien vu les difficultés de
mise en œuvre de texelois déjà voté
comment est-ce que vous vous envisagez
ce nouveau pouvoir est de la même
manière comment est-ce que vous pouvez
vous
nourrir de ce que de votre travail
aujourd'hui fait accompli avec la
plateforme Pharos
à l'égard de ce de ce pouvoir j'en viens
à la CNIL madame la Présidente vous avez
touché du doigt deux reprises la
question des moyens de la CNIL est-ce
que vous avez une évaluation
de ces nouveaux moyens dont la CNIL
aurait besoin
u égard à l'ampleur des missions qui
vous seraient confiait ce que vous avez
une idée dans déjà aller à l'échéance de
ce texte de
de cet ordre là voilà madame présidente
les questions que j'avais à poser à
plutôt à deux de nos présidents mais en
tout cas la question générale aux trois
présents que je remercie de leur
présentation extrêmement complexe qui
ont fait que j'ai des questions assez
restreintes
qui est essentiel mais il y a aussi
toute la question du harcèlement de nos
jeunes avec des conséquences dramatiques
on a encore vu ça ces derniers jours
concrètement expliquez-nous comment le
nouveau texte va vous permettre nous
l'espérons de
cette question merci
vous aviez quelque chose j'ai
l'impression que je connais concerné
enfin l'ARCEP plutôt et concerné que par
la première question qui est le
panachage des collèges d'autorité donc
juste un petit mot d'abord pour vous
rappeler que la coopération est bonne et
qu'on se voit régulièrement et qu'on
échange régulièrement que le fait qu'un
président
d'une autorité de l'ARCEP par exemple
soit membre du collège de la CNIL par
droit et vice-versa
me paraît pas forcément la meilleure
solution parce qu'on peut avoir un effet
de biais qui est que la décision d'une
autorité
emporterait la vie de l'autre en fait au
moins en communication à l'extérieur
c'est à dire typiquement larcèle à un
membre de l'acnil en son sein on prend
une décision c'est pas forcément avec
l'accord du nom de la CNIL on peut par
exemple et quelquefois on n'a pas
nécessairement l'unanimité dans les
décisions qu'on prend mais on prend une
décision et on aurait l'impression de
l'extérieur que la CNIL a validé ainsi
la décision de l'arccepte donc moi je
suis pas favorable je préfère de loin
les avis croisés ou chacun autorité
selon
ses objectifs de régulation on est trois
autorités avec des objectifs de
régulation différents vous l'avez dit en
introduction plutôt les contenus pour
l'arcom plutôt de la défense des
libertés individuelles pour l'acnil et
plutôt
une autorité pro concurrence régulateur
économique on est un régulateur
économique pro concurrence qu'on puisse
rendre des avis chacun dans nos dans nos
objectifs de compétences par des avis
croisés ça me paraît plus effi plus
voilà je et simplement vous dire que les
coopérations en fait entre autorité
existe on a des collèges communs avec la
commerciale il n'y a pas eu besoin
d'ailleurs de textes de loi pour qu'on
le mette en place donc une à deux fois
par an on a des collèges communs avec
harcèle Arcom et on a aussi
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure un pôle
de travail ensemble commun entre l'art
comme et l'ARCEP cette coopération elle
doit exister naturellement au niveau des
collèges mais elle doit aussi exister
par des groupes de travail commun ou par
des pôles communs au niveau des équipes
c'est absolument essentiel et donc voilà
donc j'ai un avis assez réservé sur le
panachage des autorités
merci alors monsieur le Président avec
cette question aussi de harcèle sur le
premier point je fais volontiers
je pense que les mécanismes de
consultation d'une part telle qu'ils
sont prévus par les textes ou tels que
nous les pratiquons nous-mêmes voilà
chaque fois une problématique intéresse
une autre autorité
la consulter formellement soit parce que
les textes le prévoit nous avons suggéré
là en l'occurrence d'instaurer une
procédure formelle s'agissant de la
protection des mineurs dans le texte qui
vous est soumis soit par notre pratique
ce qui se ce qui se fait entre nous
la mécanique des conventions qui est un
dispositif souple mais tout à fait
efficace c'est ce qu'on a fait au moment
où j'ai pris mes fonctions avec la
recette on a conclu une convention et on
a décidé de créer un service commun les
procédures d'audition
périodique
Marie-Laure Denis avait eu la
gentillesse de me convier pour une
intervention devant le collège de la
CNIL il y a quelques semaines elle a
bien voulu répondre à notre invitation
devant le collège de l'arcom nous avons
reçu il y a peu de temps le président de
l'Autorité de la concurrence devant le
collège je suis moi-même auditionnel
cette semaine par le collège de
l'Autorité de la concurrence ce type de
mécanisme me paraît me paraît préférable
nous avons les uns les autres des
collèges qui sont déjà en nombre la CNIL
le collège le plus le plus important je
rappelle que l'art comme un un collège
composé de neuf membres permanents donc
plutôt qu'une présence supplémentaire
institutionnelle il me semble que les
mécanismes que nous avons évoqué sont
plus sans plus adaptés sur les lacunes à
ce stade pour ma part je n'en identifie
pas mais
nous irons en marchant si je peux dire
alors le référentiel vous avez raison
sera bien sûr un sujet important je
rappelle je l'ai dit dans mon propos
introductif je l'ai souligné devant vous
hier soir que nous attendons une
décision de justice le
7 juillet donc
je serai précautionneux dans mes exposés
en attendant cette décision prochaine de
la justice nous travaillons sur ce sujet
avec la CNIL d'une part et le pérenne
d'autre part pour bien
préparer ce document qui je pense sera
prêt sera prêt à l'automne je souligne
qu'on échappera certainement pas sur ce
sur ce volet là à une consultation de
niveau européen le regard de la nature
du texte la notification à Bruxelles
sur les procédures d'injonction donc
comme je l'ai souligné dans mon propos
introductif donc la lecture qu'on fait
du projet de loi qui nous est soumis il
y a deux types de dispositions distincts
entre l'article 1 et l'article 2
l'article 1 tel que le comprend donc
vise plus spécifiquement des dispositifs
de vérification d'âge qui ne
respecterait pas suffisamment la vie
privée
au regard du référentiel qui aura été
bâti par l'arcom après avis de l'acnil
et la collaboration du pérenne et donc
dans ce cas de figure le texte évoque la
possibilité de mise en demeure et de
sanctions financières et puis l'article
2 qui on a bien compris le texte vise
l'absence de mise en place d'un
dispositif efficace de vérification de
l'âge qui pourrait conduire à ce
moment-là l'autorité a demandé le
blocage du site mais cet article 2 ne
fait pas référence lui-même au
référentiel donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle devant votre
lors de l'audition d'hier soir et à
nouveau ce matin il nous semble dans une
optimisation du texte à la CNIL comme à
nous-mêmes Marie-Laure Denis
préciser sa position que nous pourrions
harmoniser ces deux articles en un seul
prévoir effectivement une mesure de
consultation formelle de l'acnil par
l'arcom dans l'hypothèse ou on sera
amené à faire un constat d'un dispositif
mis en oeuvre par un site qui porterait
atteinte de façon excessive à la vie
privée en regard du référentiel que nous
aurons élaboré mais en tout cas d'avoir
une seule
un seul schéma de procédure pour éviter
ces zones ces zones d'ambiguïté voilà
alors la question du harcèlement et bien
évidemment une question centrale madame
la Présidente pour
pour tout vous dire je vois aujourd'hui
même après cette audition le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour en parler en
parler avec lui le Règlement sur les
services numériques
a pour objet et pour ambition comme vous
le savez de conduire les sites qui
seront couverts par ce texte de lutter
contre toutes les tous les contenus de
nature illicite mais de viser plus
spécifiquement tous ceux qui après la
haine en ligne et aux mécanismes de
harcèlement avec l'obligation pour ces
sites d'une part de procédés à
l'évaluation des risques de nature
systémiques chacune de leurs plateformes
peut comporter d'imposer à ces sites des
mécanismes annuels d'audit externes pour
vérifier les dispositifs qu'il mettent
en place soit d'intelligence
artificielle soit de modération de
maturation humaine l'obligation pour ces
sites de mettre leurs données à
disposition de la sphère académique pour
qu'il puisse mener leurs travaux de
recherche et contrôler notamment la
façon dont leurs algorithmes procèdent
donner aux autorités de régulation un
pouvoir de sanction sera un pouvoir de
sanction important puisque en
l'occurrence les sanctions pourront
aller jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial
donc c'est bien évidemment une voie de
réponse très importante alors et après
tout est bien évidemment dans un ordre
un ordre d'exécution mais lors de vérité
va sonner très vite
ce règlement pour les très grandes
plateformes sera effectivement à partir
de la fin du mois d'août de cette année
Twitter Elon Musk
répondit au DSA fin août Tik Tok tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui répond-il
aux dispositions du DSA la réponse va se
poser très vite et pour l'Union
européenne pour la Commission pour la
gouvernance de ce texte lors de vérité
sonnera nécessairement très très
rapidement et il y a un enjeu de
crédibilité qui est tout à fait tout à
fait essentiel j'ajoute qu'il y a une
autre dimension qui est bien évidemment
essentielle c'est le volet éducation
éducation aux médias et l'éducation à ce
que je serai tenté d'appeler en tout cas
ce que nous sommes tentés d'appeler à
l'arcom l'éducation à la citoyenneté
numérique maintenant c'est plus
seulement les questions de l'éducation
aux médias de savoir utiliser ces outils
c'est comment très tôt on fait
l'apprentissage d'une citoyenneté
numérique c'est pas parce que on ouvre
un compte sur tip-top sur Facebook ou
sur Twitter que du jour au lendemain on
doit se transformer en délinquant
potentiel harceler ses camarades de
classe un jour prochain ou à faire
circuler des fausses informations et
donc là il y a effectivement un travail
en amont un travail éducatif qui est
extrêmement extrêmement important
s en complément aux questions merci
beaucoup merci madame la Présidente donc
en ce qui concerne l'éventuelle
élargissement du collège de la CNIL et
des autres autorités concernées c'est
vrai qu'elle a été reprise hier où
l'avait souligné monsieur le rapporteur
dans la proposition de loi sur la
reconnaissance faciale une idée qui
avait été exprimée dans le rapport de
Philippe Platon et de Philippe Gosselin
à l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'utilisation des images de sécurité
dans le domaine public pour lutter
contre l'insécurité mais ce que disait
précisément cette recommandation numéro
36 de ce rapport
c'était
l'idée de d'élargir le collège de la
CNIL était le pendant du fait que cette
proposition proposait enfin une
proposition suggérait de consacrer
l'acné en tant que chef de fil de la
régulation des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle donc c'était
pour une compétence très particulière
très structurant donc naturellement il
appartient aux législateur de voir ce
qui veut faire au sujet de cette
élargissement mais
ça a d'autant plus de sens qui aurait
une compétence très structurante ou pas
sinon on fait déjà beaucoup
d'intercrégulation
lors de la redière hérault-olivier mask
l'ont rappelé on le fait de façon
structurelle à la CNIL avec le président
de la cadaq et membre de droit
d'ailleurs de comme la rappeler Loïc
Hervé de notre collège avec une voix
tout à fait délibérative et la Défenseur
des droits et aussi membre de droite de
notre collège mais avec une voix
consultative et reconnaisse a aussi
souligner
en passant que notre collège comportait
déjà 18 membres en fait ce qui est
peut-être peut-être pas le collège le
plus important en nombre de l'ensemble
des autorités administratives
indépendantes mais en tout cas des
autorités de régulation très
probablement
sur les lacunes moi j'en ai pas décelé
au-delà de ce que j'ai pu exprimer dans
dans mon propos liminaire de souhait de
précision il y a quand même un sujet
notamment sur la mise en oeuvre du
disposition du DSA etc il y a quand même
des pouvoirs de sanctions et d'enquête
de la CNIL qui sont
précisés modifiés etc il faudrait par
cohérence qu'à un moment ou un autre
dans les textes il concernent la CNIL
dans la loi de 78 dans le décret
d'application etc toutes ces règles
concernant nos procédures répressives
soient un peu
harmonisé ou écrite parce que sinon ça
peut être compliqué quand même pour les
acteurs de si retrouver
je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit le
président de la recom sur le fait qu'ils
nous semblerait
salissant du contrôle de l'âge utile de
fusionner les articles premiers et de de
la loi par cohérence et
qui est une saisine formelle de la CNIL
par l'arceèle en cas de
manquement concernant un site
pornographique qui pourrait concerner
nos compétences et puis monsieur
sénateur Hervé vous avez parlé des
moyens de l'acnil donc il faudra qu'on
précise enfin que les choses soient
davantage précisé notamment aussi quand
il y aura un décret d'application sur le
filtre cyber-arnaque et le rôle de
l'autorité administrative qui sera en
première ligne et le rôle du membre du
collège de l'acné il est donc des
services de la CNIL qui pourrait
potentiellement se voir envoyer 1000 URL
de site par jour et tout ça avec des
possibilités de recours suspensives donc
il y a quand même un enjeu fort à ce que
on puisse être efficace et qu'on puisse
répondre
c'est sûr qu'avec 200
70 agents à la fin de l'année dernière
sachant que on nous voit beaucoup comme
le gendarme de la protection des données
mais ce que voit moins un certain nombre
de personnes c'est qu'on fait aussi
beaucoup
alors gendarmes de la protection des
données pour traiter les 12 à 14000
plaintes qu'on apparent prononcer un
certain nombre de sanctions faire des
contrôles
le but étant la mise en conformité
d'ailleurs pas nécessairement la
sanction pour la sanction on fait aussi
beaucoup d'accompagnement
beaucoup pour les entreprises innovantes
dans le domaine du numérique on a créé
un bac à sable c'est la troisième année
pour accompagner des entreprises
innovantes il y a deux ans c'était sur
la santé en numérique l'année dernière
c'était sur
les outils numériques dans l'éducation
cette année ça sera sur l'intelligence
artificielle et les administrations on a
créé aussi un accompagnement renforcé ou
pendant 6 mois on accompagne des
entreprises très fort potentielles de
développement économique et numérique
l'idée pour dire les choses clairement
c'était qu'on se dit que ça aurait été
intéressant pour la Cnil d'accompagner
doctolib au moment de sa création
plutôt qu'un moment où doctolib est très
installé à beaucoup de traitements de
données on a eu on a fait un appel à
candidature cette année on a eu 50 47
très exactement entreprises innovantes
et de développement enfin et à fort
potentiel de développement économique
qui ont souhaité t'accompagner par la
CNIL en matière de protection des
données c'est dire que on n'est pas
juste assimilé à un
rôle de gendarme de la protection des
données et après je crois qu'on est la
seule autorité de protection des données
en Europe à avoir un laboratoire
d'innovation numérique à essayer de
soulever le capot d'un certain nombre de
d'innovations les assistants vocaux
l'intelligence artificielle on vient de
créer un service sur l'intelligence
artificielle
demain oui demain on fait pour la
deuxième fois un privacy Racer ou l'idée
c'est de faire des ponts entre les
régulateurs les entreprises et les
chercheurs l'année dernière pour la
première édition il y a 4000 personnes
qui ont suivi ce privilégier donc sur
les enjeux entre recherche régulation
entreprise en matière de protection des
données et donc pour le filtre
anti-arnac très concrètement je pense
qu'il faudra des moyens supplémentaires
pour l'acnil indépendamment de ceux qui
sont potentiellement déjà budgétés s'ils
sont confirmés pour l'année prochaine si
on veut garantir l'efficacité de ce
dispositif
petite remarque au passage on vous
remercie madame la Présidente et
quelques jours la commission de la
culture recevait Jacques Toubon à
l'occasion des 40 ans de la Loi sur la
défense du français
ça me dérange d'entendre
je sais pas quoi je pense qu'on a des
termes français utilisé alors c'est vrai
c'est vrai que la ma langue a fourché
parce qu'on s'y emploie et d'ailleurs et
il a raison le
certaines personnes certains citoyens ne
manquent pas de nous reprendre quand on
utilise des termes et comme j'ai de
beaucoup de sympathie pour Jacques
Toubon je ne voudrais en aucune façon
voilà le
mécontenté donc je reformulerai
autrement cette phrase alors je donne la
parole à notre deuxième rapporteur
Patrick chaise pour l'autre volet
merci
Président mes chers collègues alors j'ai
essayé de cibler mes questions parce que
le temps passe je sais que mes collègues
sont aussi impatients de vous poser tout
un tas de questions je vais déjà donc
cibler l'article 6 de ce texte et
notamment sur certains article 6 je
voudrais savoir de quelle façon les
autorités que vous représentez
contribueront au déploiement du filtre
anti arnaque
qui est donc prévu à cet article la mise
en place d'un dispositif ordonné par
voie administrative plutôt que par voie
judiciaire vous semble-t-elle plus
efficace
enfin plus spécifiquement pour la Cnil
donc qui est donc décidé comme autorité
garante du caractère adapté proportionné
des mesures prises dans le cas de ce
dispositif qui sera la personnalité
qualifiée en tout cas qui leur sera son
profil au sein de la CNIL pour assurer
ce rôle sur la régulation du marché de
l'informatique en nuage madame
présidente
l'encadrement des crédits et la
suppression des frais de transfert
sortant de données le projet de loi donc
attribué à l'ARCEP un nouveau rôle de
gendarmes de l'informatique en nuage
la présence est de vous satisfaite de ce
nouveau rôle
sur les services d'intermédiation de
données donc d'autres États membres
ont-ils effectué ou ont-ils manifesté
l'intention d'effectuer un autre choix
que la désignation de leur autorité de
régulation des télécommunications comme
seules compétentes pour l'application du
Data Act donc concerne l'article 11 j'ai
compris même la présidente de la
clinique vous aviez des propositions à
nous faire donc je suis bien sûr ouvert
à cela une compétence notamment de
l'ARCEP et de la CNIL exercé en commun
ou partager à telle été envisagée et en
fait les avantages et inconvénients de
une telle solution aurait-elle présentée
sur l'article 25 sur l'article 25 qui
concerne les procédures de saisine et de
visites de l'arcom en quoi est-il
nécessaire de préciser dans la loi que
les autorités compétentes pour la mise
en oeuvre du Règlement sur les services
numériques coopèrent étroitement
se prêtent mutuellement assistance et se
communique librement des informations ça
fait un peu lecture du code civil des
mariages
quel sera l'objet des conventions de
coopération vous allez signer et
pourriez-vous nous en dire davantage sur
ces conventions
la procédure de saisine et des visites
des locaux fournisseurs de des services
entre 6 heures et 21h nous interpelle
donc dans la rédaction c'est la
procédure ne peut être autorisée que par
le juge des libertés et la détention il
est prévu que toutes les conditions de
réalisation de cette procédure soit
fixées par voie réglementaire ce qui
donc nous étonne un peu je voudrais
avoir votre avis sur cette question et
peut-être que vous puissiez nous
détailler la procédure la procédure qui
est prévue qui qui s'apparente on peut
le viser comme ça à une perquisition
voilà ma présidente rapidement les
questions que je souhaitais poser merci
alors je rends un rôle au président et
présidente qui souhaite la prendre en
premier Paname Denis merci madame la
Présidente donc monsieur rapporteur sur
l'article 6 donc le filtre national de
cybersécurité donc le projet de loi
prévoit effectivement la création d'un
filtre national qui permet d'alerter les
internautes on parle le billet d'un
message d'alerte dans leur navigateur
lorsqu'il souhaite accéder en fait un
site malveillant donc tout le sujet ça
consiste à avoir des garanties entre les
tout ce sujet consiste à avoir des
garanties entre l'efficacité de ce
filtre effectivement et d'avoir des
garanties en matière de liberté de
communication et d'expression c'est
c'est pour ça que le texte prévoit et
reprenant cela largement la vie du
Conseil d'État enfin un certain nombre
de procédures avec des délais d'abord un
avertissement le cas échéant après un
blocage etc pour répondre directement à
votre question de ce que je comprends du
texte ça serait un membre du collège de
la CN qui serait donc indépendant qui
serait la personnalité qualifiée
mentionnée dans l'article 6 pour
s'assurer du caractère justifié des
mesures et des conditions
d'établissement et de mise à jour et de
communication de l'utilisation de la
liste des adresses électroniques
concernés mais naturellement nous ne
pourrons désigner cette personnalité
qualifiée que quand le décret
d'application qui est prévu dans le
texte
sera
pris
notre message principal c'est que en
arriver au blocage c'est évidemment
quelque chose d'envisageable et qui doit
être envisagé mais dans notre esprit que
pour les cas les plus graves et puis la
question des modalités et des moyens qui
vont être précisé
s'agissant des services d'intermédiaires
de données donc comme j'ai pu le dire
dans mon propos
libinaire
il nous semble important que la CNIL
soit saisie pour avis
systématiquement et au préalable de tout
déclaration en fait d'un intermédiaire
de données auprès de la recette pour que
ce soit la CNIL dont c'est la compétence
qui précise parmi ces données s'il y a
des données personnelles et quelles sont
les règles qui s'appliquent à ces
acteurs et par sécurité juridique y
compris et par lisibilité sur ces textes
qui sont complexes y compris pour les
acteurs concernés ils nous semblerait
utile que si la recette ou la CNIL
édicte des règles droits souple sur le
sujet des intermédiaires de données y
est une consultation préalable là aussi
systématique de l'autre autorité
concernés et puis
dans le texte je crois que c'est
l'article 13
il y a au deuxième monde d'articles 13
un locataire échéant que pour ma part je
ne comprends pas et que je me suis
primerai et que je proposerai de
supprimer parce qu'il est ambigu ou
c'est à propos de la consultation de la
CNIL par l'ARCEP
dans les conditions fixées par décret
c'est autorité recueille le cas échéant
les observations éventuelles de la
commission par rapport à des demandes
qui peuvent concerner un règlement sur
la gouvernance européenne des données je
vois pas très bien pourquoi il y a un
local échéant que je suggérer de
supprimer voilà Monsieur rapporteur en
ce qui me concerne merci merci monsieur
le Président de LARCOM
de la coopération donc
l'équilibre que le taxe propose donc en
fixant les grands principes de cette
coopération dans la loi mais en
renvoyant la modalités de ces
coopérations entre les uns et les autres
à des outils plus souples du type du
type convention nous paraît le
dispositif adapté c'est vrai que la
nature des informations qu'on va
échanger peut avoir un caractère
sensible et de ce point de vue là avoir
une référence de nature législative nous
paraît nous par importante chaque
autorité on l'a vu dans les
interventions respectives
de madame Denis et Madame de La redière
à des champs de compétences propres sur
la mise en oeuvre du DSA on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure
on aura des attributions respectives les
uns les autres à faire valoir et donc
c'est ça qui est utile de de couvrir par
la Convention au regard de nos
attributions respectives pour bien fixer
les modalités de cette coopération
entre nous et sur les pouvoirs de visite
si j'ose dire bon c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu inspiré de les pouvoirs
dont on peut disposer l'Autorité de la
concurrence
on est en face de soi des acteurs qui
sont des acteurs puissants donc voilà de
telle autorité
c'est des acteurs avec lesquels il faut
pouvoir dialoguer dans une position qui
n'est pas une position de faiblesse
madame de La Rodière
oui
merci
merci de votre question sur
la façon dont la recette accueille ces
nouvelles compétences totalement en
matière d'informatique en nuage on pense
que c'est ce que j'ai dit on l'accueille
très favorablement parce qu'on pense que
c'est un marché qui doit être
déverrouillé qu'il y a à la fois des
des freins contractuels mais aussi des
freins techniques liés à la migration
des clients vers d'autres fournisseurs
que l'ensemble qu'il y a une
concentration du marché à 70% autour de
trois quatre fournisseurs tous
américains et que si on veut faire
émerger des entreprises européennes
puissantes dans secteur et il y a aussi
des il faut déverrouiller le marché ça
il y a un enjeu économique parce que
c'est un marché en croissance évidemment
mais il y a aussi un enjeu de
souveraineté pour l'Europe de pouvoir
faire émerger ce type d'acteur et de
proposer des solutions souveraines
d'hébergement des services informatiques
et de différents services informatiques
en nuages
on l'agde d'autant plus favorablement
qu'on ait un régulateur
techniqueo-économique
du numérique que notre expertise
technique et notre culture d'ouverture
des écosystèmes numériques nous motive
beaucoup à prendre en compte cette
nouvelle compétence et ce niveau marché
à déverrouiller
concernant
tout le monde a parlé des moyens
nécessaires aussi on aura besoin de
moyenne nécessaire alors c'est possible
pour prendre ces nouvelles compétences
que ça soit sur l'informatique en nuage
ou sur le Data gouvernancect parce que
on n'a pas on nous retire pas de
compétences c'est que aujourd'hui
exactement comme à l'arcome et la CNIL
je crois qu'on a des personnes et des
salariés à la recette qui sont très très
occupés et que d'ailleurs
quelquefois certains d'entre vous ou
quelquefois des acteurs nous disent
qu'on n'est pas suffisamment réactif ou
mais c'est souvent qu'une question de
moyens derrière
et donc il faudra penser à prendre en
compte cette demande lors de la loi de
finances de 2024
un mot sur la question de l'exercice en
commun de la compétence sur les
prestacteurs de sa vie intermédiation de
données
c'est très complexe en fait ça serait
très complexe à la fois pour les acteurs
mais aussi pour les autorités
d'exercer ensemble une compétence
au sein deux autorités qui
n'ont pas été créés pour les mêmes
objectifs les mêmes enjeux qui n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes cultures de
régulation ça me paraît très très
complexe donc je trouve pas que ça
serait une bonne idée que de modifier
l'architecture actuelle du texte sur le
DGA un point aussi pour
dire que
le DGA prévoit une notification
systématique par l'ARCEP de l'ensemble
des personnes des prestataires de
services d'intermédiation de données qui
se déclaré auprès de la recette et donc
nous nous allons notifier à la
Commission européenne à chaque fois qui
est un prestataire international de
données qui va se déclarer la Commission
européenne a prévu de rendre public ces
déclarations donc voilà et je pense que
c'est pour cette raison que le texte ne
prévoit pas que leur sept notifie
à la CNIL c'est globalement ça sera
public et l'ensemble des acteurs qu'il
souhaite pourront s'il peut me permettre
une petite précision moi c'est pas pour
que ça soit public ou pas public c'est
que dans les jeux de données il y a des
données personnelles potentiellement et
des données non personnelles donc ça
permet en notifiant à la CNIL de pouvoir
je vais essayer de manger le micro de
pouvoir informer ces acteurs qu'ils le
sachent c'est quand même très complexe
pour les acteurs d'avoir à la fois le
DGA le rgpd etc
qui sont potentiellement soumis à deux
législations donc je on voit pas bien en
quoi
dans mon esprit la notification à la
Commission européenne
n'est pas la même chose n'a pas le même
objectif que la notification à la CNIL à
qui il appartient de qualifier sur des
acteurs qu'on connaît très largement et
il y en a pas 36000 parce que dans la
l'analyse d'impact de la Commission
européenne sur les services
intermédiation de données je crois qu'il
y avait à peu près une cinquantaine
d'acteurs identifiés en B2B alors j'ose
pas dire en B2B en affaires tout à faire
ou à faire et en B jusqu'à C il y en
avait aussi une cinquantaine et à très
court terme il y a peut-être une
demi-douzaine d'acteurs qui est
concernée en réalité donc je vois pas
très bien où est l'impossibilité et j'ai
congé de de notifier à l'acné parce que
c'est quand même à l'acnil qui
appartient de déterminer sur les acteurs
qu'on connaît aussi très largement s'il
y a des données personnelles ou pas
je reprends simplement parce que sur le
les
par rapport à le cas échéant ce qui est
précisé dans latex dans le texte et
aussi par rapport à le fait qu'il y a
pas d'obligation de saisie mais qui a
une obligation de saisie uniquement
quand il y a un impact sur les données
personnelles la logique et la même c'est
qu'il y a des il y a des prestataires de
services d'intermédiation de données qui
vont offrir des services avec juste et
uniquement des données industrielles
c'est à dire que c'est un nouveau champ
en fait d'activité qui est sans cesse
développer avec ce texte et qui touche
beaucoup plus les données industrielles
et donner économiques des acteurs elles
partagent au sein d'un secteur de donner
économiques et industrielle et pas
nécessairement des données personnelles
et donc c'est pour ça que le texte comme
le DGA d'ailleurs prévoit une
articulation de ce type là et juste sur
ce point je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lors de la redire sur le fait que
pour les acteurs qui est essentiellement
des données industrielles ça relève
totalement du DGA et de la compétence de
leur seule je précise simplement mais
c'est un point de détail c'est pas que
dans les données industrielles il peut y
avoir des données personnelles des
données de clients des données de
salariés etc donc encore une fois je
pense que c'est important pour les
acteurs qui sachent qui a
potentiellement de séries de textes sur
deux types de données différentes
sachant que en plus quand les données
sont inextricablement liées entre les
données personnelles et les données qui
ne le sont pas elles basculent du côté
du rgpd tout ça est très compliqué mais
c'est pour dire que tout ce qui pourra
renforcer les mécanismes de coopération
et d'articulation entre nos deux
autorités je ne doute pas que ça sera le
temps c'est dommage que c'était anticipe
un peu le Data hack parce que le datac
venait équilibrer aussi
en tout cas prévaudra toujours le rgpd
madame Denis voilà extrêmement vigilant
mais vous avez raison de dire de les
donner industrielles pour qu'elles
soient brutes pour aussi ne pas porter
préjudice aux entreprises
de les partager et que en effet ça peut
être corrélade et des Dédé personnels il
faut être très vigilant
juste pour conclure parce que
je voulais dire c'est vraiment sans
préjudice du rgpd
voilà merci alors j'ai si demande de
prise de parole trois concernent je
pense la lutte contre la
pédopornographie trois autres d'autres
sujets donc je vous donne la parole on
vous demande je suis désolé de vous
contraindre d'être très synthétique vu
le temps qui nous appartient dans les
réunions de groupe donc Annick billon
Marie Mercier Laurence Rossignol vous
avez la parole successivement et je
donnerai la parole à recolivier Metz
pour vous répondre et ensuite
Pierre-Antoine Livry Alexandra borchio
Fontain et Florence matrix merci madame
la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président et mesdames les présidentes
pour déjà les nombreuses réponses que
vous avez données au rapporteur et à la
Présidente je reviendrai évidemment sur
l'industrie de la pornographie les sites
pornographiques ayant été auteurs avec
mes collègues
du rapport porno l'enfer du décor on le
voit il y a des nouveaux nouveaux
pouvoirs de sanctions et de blocage qui
sont donnés à l'arcom
je voudrais juste savoir si vous
imaginez dans l'état actuel de ces
nouveaux pouvoirs
réussir à agir puisque on l'a démontré
dans notre rapport les sites
pornographiques sont souvent dirigés
depuis des paradis fiscaux donc quel est
fait aura auront ces nouveaux pouvoirs à
la fois de sanctions et de blocage
administratif et ma question rejoignait
sur les moyens supplémentaires donc elle
est valable pour les trois les trois
organismes nous recevons ce matin
ensuite moi je me pose une question
quand même
importante et qui rejoindra aussi
les le retrait des contenus pédaux
pornographiques quid de la définition
des contenus illicites et quid de la
définition d'un contenu
pédopornographique parce que il a été
question de pilosité des questions de
grosseur de seins sur les images donc
comment réussir à définir est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut aller plus loin
dans la définition pour une meilleure
efficacité et ma dernière question
madame la Présidente sur le dispositif
CNIL pérenne qui est actuellement en
test avec le groupe Dorsel avez-vous des
des retours
merci Marie Mercier
merci Madame merci Madame Rossignol
toujours sur le même thème absolument
sur le même thème la question s'adresse
effectivement à la présence de la CNIL
le président de la traînera par rigueur
on a échangé longuement hier après-midi
quant à la présidente de la recette je
n'ai aucune compétence pour l'interroger
et donc je vais vous épargner de
l'étaler mon incompétence sur les
questions numériques en général mais ma
question est assez similaire à celle qui
a de poser Marie Mercier en fait vous
avez madame la Présidente de la clinique
dit tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
toujours veiller à la fois à la
protection des mineurs et à la
protection des données personnelles or
j'ai le sentiment mais là encore comme
je ne suis pas une spécialiste du sujet
peut-être je me trompe que lorsqu'il
s'agit des données personnelles des
consommateurs
des sites pornos on applique pas
exactement les mêmes règles qu'en ce qui
concerne les
utilisateurs d'autres sites j'ai cru
comprendre que sur les données
personnelles il fallait aussi il fallait
veiller à ce qu'elle ne circule pas et
que le but notre but était la protection
Marie Mercier l'a dit en ce qui concerne
les mineurs sur la fréquentation des
sites de jeux d'argent en ligne la règle
est assez crée est claire ces cartes de
crédit
et
épreuve de l'âge
donc là on ne se pose pas la question
d'une particulière protection des
données pour ceux qui s'inscrivent sur
les sites de jeux en ligne mais en
revanche pour les gens qui fréquentent
les sites porno on se poserait la
question pourquoi je ne comprends pas
cette distinction et pour qu'on
n'applique pas aussi de pornographique
la règle qu'on applique au site de jeux
en ligne l'argent qu'est-ce qu'il y
aurait de particulier à protéger dans
les données des consommateurs de porno
merci mesdames pour votre concision
alors Monsieur Mestre
merci madame la Présidente
plusieurs observations pour répondre aux
questions qui m'ont été
posées d'abord
pour souligner mais vous le savez bien
compte tenu des travaux que le Sénat
amené l'ampleur du phénomène nous avons
publié il y a très peu de temps une
étude très complète sur l'accès à ces
sites de la part des mineurs qu'on a pu
conduire avec notamment Mediamétrie donc
des mesures très très concrètes et on a
pu mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène
l'âge de plus en plus bas de
consultation de ces sites le fait que
cette consultation se fait très
largement maintenant par l'intermédiaire
de téléphone
qui ne disposent pas de contrôle
parental très souvent et donc sans que
les parents soient eux-mêmes en
situation ne pouvant s'assurer de ce que
leurs enfants font donc on a par
ailleurs une documentation maintenant
très très importante le Sénat l'a évoqué
largement sur les effets de cette
consultation sur les comportements sur
la sexualité des jeunes gens et la suite
de leur vie sur les relations entre les
hommes et les femmes donc l'ampleur du
phénomène est aujourd'hui bien bien
connu je crois que le pignon public a
largement bougé sur ces sujets là si
vous pouvez y avoir des effets de
tolérance il y a encore quelques
décennies
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui la justice
elle-même s'est mise en mouvement
justice pénale comme vous le savez il y
a des actions judiciaires qui sont
aujourd'hui en cours sur l'industrie
l'industrie porno donc les lignes sont
en train de bouger mais votre remarque
madame billon madame Mercier et Madame
Rossignol vous remarques sont très
justes
je suis frappé honnêtement que sur un
texte de cette nature qui date
maintenant de trois ans il y a pas eu la
moindre initiative
tentative pour essayer tout simplement
de se conformer une réglementation
réglementation madame Mercier qui
d'ailleurs ne date pas spécifiquement de
2020 puisque l'interdiction d'exposer
des mineurs à des contenus
pénographiques et dans le code pénal
depuis de très nombreuses années
on a fait fasse c'est vraiment je
souhaite vous le dire mais vous le savez
vous avez entendu la reconnaît plusieurs
reprises ou les représentants du collège
qui suivent ses affaires très
directement on n'a pas ménagé notre
peine sur cette affaire pour la mise en
oeuvre de ce de ce texte je rappelle que
chaque fois pour nous c'est bien
évidemment des procédures de constat
d'huissier qu'on est obligé de mener
pour s'assurer que les sites se
conforment se conforment pas
chaque fois pour chaque mise en demeure
c'est des notifications
au niveau européen des notifications au
régulateur nationaux puisque la plupart
de ces sites sont implantes à l'étranger
donc je vous passe les détails sur les
difficultés matérielles chaque acte que
nous avons pris a été contesté donc les
mises en demeure c'était devant le juge
administratif le décret d'application du
texte contesté devant le juge
administratif bien évidemment décupler
ses présenter devant le juge
administratif le même circuit devant le
juge judiciaire
procédure vous l'avez évoqué madame
Mercier de médiation qui nous a beaucoup
surpris puisque en quelque sorte on
demandait une médiation entre le
gendarme et le voleur alors que la loi
nous donne comme simple mission de
constater si les sites se conforment ou
pas au disposition du Code pénal donc on
a chaque fois bien évidemment jouer le
jeu
nous sommes une autorité qui par
définition et par nature se conforme à
la loi cette médiation a donné ce
qu'elle devait donner donc elle a fait
pshit pour reprendre une expression qui
a fait Flores il y a quelques années et
donc maintenant on est suspendu à la
décision du jeu judiciaire donc on verra
ce que le juge décide le 7 alors est-ce
que le texte qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui va va tout résoudre
écoutez les gens j'en accepte legure
effectivement rentre dans un schéma plus
classique de régulation par le biais
d'une autorité administrative donc il se
voit de TL du pouvoir direct de pouvoir
prononcer une mesure de blocage et de et
de des référencements bien évidemment
cette action sera menée sous le contrôle
du juge donc il faut pas bien évidemment
de se faire complètement
désillusions madame Rossignol et Madame
billon vous l'avez dit vous-même bien
évidemment le texte fera très tôt
l'objet d'une
QPC
que sera la position des juridictions
qui examineront ce texte
sera-t-elle transmise à la Cour de
cassation sera-t-elle transmise ensuite
au Conseil constitutionnel c'est pas
exclu c'est pas exclu donc voilà
le référentiel qu'on sera amené à
prendre bien évidemment pourra lui aussi
être contesté et devra toute façon faire
l'objet de mesures de notification à
Bruxelles donc on aura quand même des
délais liés à la mise en oeuvre de ce de
ce référentiel donc la procédure
contentieuse enfin vous l'avez dit
toutes les trois on est en face de nous
une industrie une industrie organisée
la Grande-Bretagne a été mise en échec
sur des dispositions de même type il y a
4-5 ans en même temps même si elle est
en train de reprendre l'initiative sur
ce sur ce terrain
ce que je peux simplement vous dire
c'est que ce texte votait l'arcome aura
comme feuille de route là comme ailleurs
la loi toute la loi et s'attachera bien
évidemment à tout faire pour assurer sa
mise en oeuvre mais la guérilla
contentieuse
assura vraisemblablement de solides
rémunération à quelques cabinets
d'avocats de la place pour quelques
années
une toute dernière question sur ce sujet
nous avons travaillé avec Ludovic et sur
le projet de règlement visant à
combattre et prévenir les abus sexuels
sur les enfants est-ce que ce texte de
règlement qui est encore en cours de
discussion va amener quelque chose de
supplémentaire va être complètement
articulé au DSA et aux mesures aussi que
la France autorise de prendre et on
passera un autre sujet après oui vous
faites bien d'évoquer le sujet j'ajoute
il y a quand même une dimension sur
laquelle on va pas du tout évoquer mais
sur laquelle nous sommes aussi en
initiative à être plusieurs de nos
collègues européens c'est le Règlement
sur les services numériques et la
Commission européenne n'a pas été
insensible à la démarche qu'on a faite
puisque certains de ces sites
rentreront très vraisemblablement dans
la mise en oeuvre du Règlement sur les
services numériques qui peut peut-être
aussi un biais un billet d'action alors
c'est vrai résoudre pas la totalité du
problème parce que tous les sites ne
rentreront pas dans cette catégorie je
rappelle qu'il y a des centaines de
sites
pornographiques et que c'est un des
éléments de consommation mensuelle les
plus importants et de consommation de
bande passante lors de la redire
pourraient le dire plus que moi tout à
fait tout à fait considérable et le
point que vous évoquez est important
c'est effectivement de trouver les
bonnes articulations juridiques
donc le point que vous évoquez est en
cours d'examen de notre côté merci
Alexandra borque au fond de
ah pardonnez-moi je n'avais pas vu que
madame Denis avait levé la main
en tout cas pour répondre aux questions
qui qui ont été posées alors sur la
question sur une expérimentation qui est
menée aujourd'hui par un groupe en
particulier je n'ai pas de retour
l'expérimentation est menée je sais que
les services techniques de la CNIL ont
des contacts avec un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui cherchent à mettre en
oeuvre justement le dispositif technique
qu'on a préconisé en travaillant avec le
pôle d'expertise de régulation numérique
de l'État le pérenne sur cette solution
de double anonymat c'est à dire
permettre qu'un tiers de confiance en
quelque sorte
certifie votre majorité sans savoir quel
site vous allez consulter et que le site
que vous consultez
voilà n'est pas accès à votre identité
parce qu'il y a des millions de
personnes qui consultent des sites
internet pour répondre à votre question
et que il ne en matière de protection
des données qui soit
identifié
ces sites avec toutes les possibilités
de hacking qu'il y a et de hackage je
peux vous dire que demain matin vous
aurez le fichier des personnes qui
consultent des sites pornographiques qui
sera dans la nature la CNIL comme pour
tous les autres non moi je connais pas
spécialement ce qui se passe pour les
jeux en ligne etc peut-être vous mieux
que moi la CNIL je me permets quand même
de le dire sur ce sujet n'avait aucune
compétence particulière pour appliquer
la disposition législative qui a été
prise la CNIL est dans son rôle en
cherchant à protéger les données des
personnes et l'acnil a d'elle-même
décidé de travailler sur des solutions
justement techniques et autres pour
concilier ces enjeux de protection de
vie privée et de protection de l'enfance
en quelle naturellement son collège est
totalement attaché que les ravages de la
consultation de la pornographie chacun
d'entre nous en est tout à fait
conscient pour les mineurs donc la CNIL
qui aurait pu entre nous rester tout à
fait dans ces chaussons entre guillemets
à regarder les balles passées entre
l'arcane qui a essayé de faire tout ce
qu'elle pouvait et les éditeurs de site
pornographiques ces retrouvez les
manches à inventer elles-mêmes en
quelques semaines c'est pas si simple
que ça une solution qui est aujourd'hui
expérimentée par le gouvernement et qui
potentiellement après cette
expérimentation pour aboutir et j'ajoute
que ce qui n'est pas tout à fait dans
son ADN le collège de la CNIL a en plus
dit mais déjà présent vous pouvez c'est
estampiller knil dans un avis de la CNIL
vous pouvez utiliser les cartes
bancaires y compris à des transactions à
0 € etc on sait que c'est une solution
imparfaite parce que un ado 17 ans il a
peut-être une carte bancaire mais celui
qui a 12 ans c'est quand même plus
compliqué d'en avoir une autre par
ailleurs la CNIL et c'était pas
nécessairement dans son ADN aussi a dit
mais dès maintenant vous pouvez utiliser
des systèmes qui existent d'estimation
de l'âge qui sont proposés par des
entreprises je vais pas citer les noms
alors l'estimation de l'âge entre 17 et
19 ans ça sera peut-être pas parfait
mais un enfant de 13 ans qui se qui se
souhaitera se connecter à un site
pornographique et ben logiquement il ne
pourra pas se connecter etc donc je
crois que la CNIL a vraiment déployé
toutes l'énergie nécessaire en très peu
de temps pour tout en assumant ses
compétences et son rôle qui est normal
essayez vraiment de faire en sorte de
faciliter le travail de l'arcom et de
répondre aux préoccupations extrêmement
légitimes qui sont les vôtres
je vais passer la parole à Alexandra
borco fonda merci
merci madame la Présidente je vais bien
sûr rebondir sur les propos en cours et
je trouve très regrettable finalement
que tout le monde autour de cette table
partage les contacts actuels et les
conséquences de l'exposition
des mineurs au contenu pornographiques
mais personne visiblement ne semble
affirmé en tout cas qu'une solution
existe qu'elle soit
alors que techniquement je pense que
rien ne l'empêche on voit que sur
d'autres sites internet ça marche donc
c'est assez décevant mais j'espère en
tout cas et Jacques crée une personne
ici en partage tout le même constat mais
je suis assez surprise que finalement
rien ne bouge malgré l'énergie de de
chacun d'entre nous ma question était
sur la coordination en fait s'adresse
pardon à monsieur le Président de la
recom et madame la Présidente de la CNIL
sur la coordination entre les
référentiels prévus par la récente
proposition de loi qui instaure une
majorité numérique
sur les réseaux sociaux et celui
justement du PGL sur le contrôle de
l'âge sur les sites pornographiques je
voulais juste connaître un petit peu
concrètement comment vous allez vous
coordonner pour essayer de parvenir
justement à ces propos itions merci
merci donc le référentiel il ressort de
la compétence de l'arcom sur le contrôle
de l'âge donc c'est l'art comme qui va
l'élaborer et l'art comme consultera la
CNIL notamment sur avant de l'adopter
définitivement notamment sur les
caractéristiques techniques
des deux
dispositifs par exemple de double
anonymat ou autre parce qu'il y a une
compétence la CNIL sur ces sujets là et
parce qu'il s'agit de concilier encore
une fois
les enjeux que nous portons les uns et
les autres je sais pas ce qu'on peut
dire de plus à ce stade parce que moi je
ne travaille pas sur ce référentiel en
ce moment
en tout cas la coordination sera bien
évidemment très très étroite et je
j'adore tout à fait à ce que Marie-Laure
Denis a dit tout à l'heure on a vraiment
mené main dans la main nos travaux et
nos réflexion ces derniers mois pour
trouver la réponse appropriée ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est
c'est que les lignes quand même bougent
bon vous avez dit que rien debout les
lignes bougent et elles bougent dans le
monde vous savez qu'un certain nombre
d'États américains ont dansé déjà pris
des législations qui vont dans le même
sens que la législation
française plusieurs États européens et
certains de mes homologues je pense
notamment mon homologue allemand ont les
mêmes initiatives que nous à l'égard de
site porno se heurtent un peu au même
difficulté que nous ou bien le dire
même s'ils ont pu déjà obtenir de la
première décision de justice alors je
pense que les lignes bougent
l'État de droit et ce qu'il est c'est
vrai qu'injusticable bien évidemment le
droit de faire valoir et de contester
des décisions qui sont prises par une
autorité
administrative attendant le 7 juillet
j'attends le 7 juillet quand même avec
confiance je fais confiance à notre
justice je crois qu'il y a quand même un
état de l'opinion sur la nécessité de
protéger les mineurs qui est aujourd'hui
très très fort il suffit de regarder le
nombre d'articles qui sont publiés
récemment j'étais très frappé quand on a
sorti il y a trois semaines notre étude
sur les statistiques qu'on a pu
rassembler sur le sujet de voir au
moment l'écho médiatique a été
considérable sur le sujet toute la
presse quotidienne régionale on a parlé
tous les médias nous ont sollicité sur
le sujet et ont couvert cette donnée
donc voilà je pense que les lignes les
lignes bougent
c'est un chantier de longue haleine il
faut pas baisser les bras en tout cas
nous on les baissera pas
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
l'Europe sont pas elle-même du sujet
jugeant que le phénomène est
suffisamment grave pour être vraiment
pris à bras le corps au plus haut niveau
madame latrice coûte alors je pense
qu'on va changer de sujet le pressant
merci merci madame la Présidente
peut-être vous interroger sur la
question de la publicité ciblée mais
avant je voulais vous dire que
avec plusieurs collègues nos craintes
concernant l'aspect coordination sur
laquelle sur lequel vous avez déjà été
interrogé à plusieurs reprises nos
craintes ne sont pas tout à fait levés
pour nous c'est vraiment une condition
d'efficacité de dispositif législatif
donc avec ma collègue Catherine Morin de
saillie dans nos rapports sur le DSA et
le DMA nous avons vraiment vu que le
modèle économique des plateformes est un
enjeu essentiel et
et il est à l'origine de nombreux effets
délétères de toutes ces plateformes donc
est-ce que la publicité vous paraît
suffisamment traité dans ce texte qui a
vocation à mieux protéger les
consommateurs c'est ma première question
et l'autre question portera sur le
marché du cloud là aussi la part des
opère des opérateurs européens à baissé
significativement presque divisé par
deux en cinq ans est-ce que vous pensez
que les mesures figurants dans ce texte
c'est-à-dire
interdiction des frais de transper
interopérabilité seront suffisants pour
permettre aux opérateurs européens de se
réinscrire dans ce marché et de se
développer
merci alors
madame la sénatrice sur votre première
observation vraiment je veux être tout à
fait catégorique sur l'état d'esprit qui
est celui des présidentes et présidents
des autorités indépendantes quand on
parle de coopération entre nous c'est
pas un 20 mots c'est vraiment d'abord
notre ADN personnel
Marie-Laure Denis au-delà nos liens
d'amitié personnel très anciens
je crois tout comme votre serviteur a le
sens du service public chevillé au corps
et quand la loi et la loi notre
quotidien c'est la loi et c'est vraiment
ça notre feuille de route et c'est ça
qu'on met en oeuvre il y a pas de
patriotisme d'autorité de susceptibilité
d'autorité l'une vis-à-vis de l'autre on
est vraiment dans un esprit de
collaboration il y a une attente du
législateur on en a plein de conscience
on porte chacun une responsabilité
particulière que nous confie le
législateur mais on essaye de construire
ensemble de la manière la plus efficace
possible l'action nécessaire pour mettre
en œuvre ce texte alors on est dans un
état de droit une fois encore on agit
dans cet état de droit mais on déploie
nos compétences avec le souci de faire
en sorte que la volonté du législateur
puisse se traduire de façon très
concrète je voudrais vraiment vous
convaincre de ça il y a pas de moins la
moindre hésitation la moindre réticence
le moindre
feuille de papier à cigarette comme on
dit entre nos autorités on est vraiment
dans cet état d'esprit et mobilisé pour
pour atteindre l'objectif qui est le
nôtre je pense sur la publicité entre
les textes de niveau européen la
présentement de Saïd les connaît bien je
pense là notamment la publicité
politique qui maintenant très clairement
encadré par les textes les textes de
niveau européen ceux qui sont pris là
d'autres textes de loi qui ont été pris
récemment je pense au texte de loi sur
les influenceurs qui peut être mis en
oeuvre récemment que la protection du
consommateur pour reprendre votre
question et quand même mieux assuré bon
après tout est un art d'exécution il
faudra s'assurer dans l'application du
texte que les choses sont bien sont bien
conformes mais mais soyez assurés de
notre détermination je pense que
Marie-Laure Denis
partagera mon sentiment merci je ne
saurais mieux dire merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente de la recette sur la
sur la question de l'informatique en
nuage
les mesures du texte sont absolument
nécessaires à la fois la partie purement
contractuelle donc
abandonner les frais de transfert et
limiter encadrés les crédits des
services d'informatique en nuage mais
aussi les mesures techniques qui sont
celles de l'interopérabilité et de la
portabilité elles sont d'autant plus
nécessaires qu'on voit se développer une
stratégie des grands utilisateurs
d'avoir plusieurs fournisseurs cloud
non seulement parce que c'est un enjeu
de résilience mais aussi parce que il y
a une volonté de protéger certaines
données sensibles des grands
utilisateurs dans des espaces de Cloud
souverain
et
hermétique aux lois extraterritoriales
de transfert des données le marché est
encore en très forte croissance donc
elles sont certainement nécessaires
est-ce que ça sera suffisant je dirais
on a la chance quand on est encore sur
un marché en très forte croissance avec
de nombreux entreprises notamment les
PME qui sont pas pleinement équipées et
donc qui laissent un potentiel en fait
pour de nouveaux acteurs de s'installer
sur le marché répondant à des enjeux de
souveraineté répondant à des objets de
de
proximité quelquefois à des choix aussi
de clients de vouloir acheter européen
donc tout tout ça fait que
c'est nécessaire de prendre ses mesures
là pour développer le marché du cloud en
Europe bien évidemment et rééquilibrer
en fait les parts de marché les acteurs
du cloud sont soumis aussi pour certains
d'entre eux au digital market actes qui
va aussi permettre certaines
dispositions utilisant à favoriser plus
de concurrence sur
l'ensemble des du marché numérique mais
aussi sur le Cloud donc c'est sans
préjudice aussi des dispositions du
digital marketact je vais compléter la
question de ma collègue Florence avec
laquelle nous avons beaucoup travaillé
ne croyez-vous pas madame la Présidente
que on va prendre des mesures on régule
ça c'est très bien mais que il faudra
par ailleurs vraiment
manifester une vraie volonté et ça vous
aurez un rôle puisque vous êtes chargé
finalement de stimuler l'innovation et
quelque part vous intéresser au marché
en France ne croyez-vous pas que il va
falloir être beaucoup plus volontariste
au niveau des autorités de ce pays pour
faire en sorte que soit confié de
manière stratégique
le marché des données d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises d'administration
ces administrations montrer l'exemple en
premier lieu en ayant recours à des
fournisseurs de Cloud européen ont
d'abord on gagnerait en souveraineté on
gagnerait aussi en soutien à
l'innovation et au développement à nos
propres
entreprises les Américains les russes et
chinoises sont pas gênés pour accorder
une préférence réelle à leur propre on
aurait là une part de solutions et on
arrêterait c'était hémorragie on voit
venir et vous l'avez cité dans votre
introduction la plupart du marché du
cloud est confié aujourd'hui au gafam il
faut bien le dire pour combien 90%
maintenant 87% je je crois savoir donc
nous croyez-vous pas que vous avez aussi
un rôle de stimulation
de ceux qui détiennent le pouvoir de
décider l'attribution de certains
marchés stratégiques au Cloud et je
complète ma question disant comment se
fait-il que la recette alors vous n'en
étiez pas présidente encore je ne pense
pas en 2020 quand on confie la
plateforme des données de santé à
Microsoft sans appel d'offres encore une
fois la recette tout de même de la
régulation de ce marché stimuler
l'innovation veiller à l'équilibre entre
les acteurs économiques n'aurait pas dû
immédiatement dire attention il n'y a
pas eu d'appel d'offres la CNIL s'est
prononcé sur ce sujet dans son domaine
de compétence parce que de donner ultra
sensible ça nous préoccupe beaucoup
voilà et je terminerai ma question en
disant ne croyez-vous pas qu'au cœur de
ce texte il serait peut-être plus urgent
d'y inscrire tout de même ce que sont
les données sensibles ce que sont les
données stratégiques pour la nation pour
au moins avoir voilà une vision globale
et un plan d'action vraiment stratégique
pour couvrir ce qui nous tient à cœur
c'est à dire les données les plus
sensibles je vous remercie
vous évoquez un sujet de grande
importance madame la Présidente
la culture de la recette je l'ai dit au
départ c'est vraiment une culture
procurrence et pour innovation et donc
on va chercher par tous les moyens à
déverrouiller le marché pour permettre
plus de migrations plus de fluidité
maintenant comme l'a dit roc Olivier
Metz l'exercice nos compétences se le
fait dans le cadre d'une de la loi
et donc si la loi ne prévoit pas
l'obligation pour les services
administratifs de prendre un service
d'informatique en nuage souverain nous
ne pourrons pas l'imposer en tout cas
aux administrations en revanche
nous exercerons nos compétences avec
l'esprit
la culture de se dire il faut qu'on
mette en place des spécificités qui
permettent à nouveaux acteurs d'émerger
donc qui soit pas suffisait qu'il soit
pas la norme des grands qui soient pas
des normes trop difficiles non plus à
acquérir pour des petits nouveaux
acteurs donc c'est cet équilibre que
nous allons veiller à avoir et nous le
faisons en fait en consultant tous les
acteurs du marché on va bien évidemment
monter en compétences par des échanges
bilatéraux avec l'ensemble des acteurs
avec des organismes de normalisation et
on mettra naturellement en consultation
publique nos propositions ce qui
permettra à chacun des acteurs concernés
nous dire attention on pense que vous
pourriez mieux faire pour pouvoir
déverrouiller le marché et permettre à
des nouveaux acteurs européens d'émergés
de faire ainsi avant de prendre une
décision à la recette on fonctionne
toujours toujours en consultation de
l'ensemble des acteurs du marché pour
pouvoir atteindre les objectifs de la
régulation qui est en l'occurrence une
objective
de développer un marché européen du
Cloud
il s'agit pas ici d'appliquer au nom une
loi qui n'existerait pas sur la
souveraineté il s'agit tout simplement
de s'émouvoir à juste titre parce qu'il
y a pas eu d'appel d'offres et que la
procédure n'a pas été respectée alors
madame la Présidente je n'ai pas la
raison de savoir pourquoi la recette n'a
pas répondu en 2020 je n'ai aucune
j'étais pas présente et j'aurais demandé
à jamais parlé donc je peux pas vous
dire pourquoi la recette à cette époque
mais je me suis quand même eu de de voir
qu'il y avait pas de réaction merci
madame la Présidente sur ce sujet là en
tout cas madame la prison le collège de
l'acnil a obtenu du gouvernement en tout
cas
des garanties s'agissant du nom
transfert du nom versement du ce qu'on
appelle le sndf le système national des
données de santé qui comprend toutes les
données de santé des Français sur la
plateforme des données de santé je ne
donne pas de l'acronyme anglais voyez je
m'améliore
précisément parce qu'il est Bergé sur
Microsoft en tout cas jusqu'à ce que
effectivement
cet hébergement de données ne soit pas
immunisée contre potentiellement des
accès d'autorité étrangère ça fait
partie
d'une action très importante que nous
avons enfin dans un dialogue en tout cas
que nous avons eu avec le gouvernement
par ailleurs la CNIL a beaucoup
travaillé avec l'ancie sur la
certification dite check new cloud qui
permet justement de sécuriser
l'hébergement des données les plus
sensibles dont la liste vient d'être
précisé par une circulaire de la Premier
ministre de la première ministre du 31
mai pour que en tout cas les
entreprises qui auront qui seront
conformes à ce référentiel c'est Kim
cloud non seulement
ne soit pas conforme au sol
préconisations
et la CNIL ensemble elles sont conformes
aussi aux exigences en matière de
transfert des données ou de non
transfert des données ou de localisation
des données des Français de façon
sécurisée voilà ce que les justes les
deux points que je voulais préciser en
complément des réponses de lors de la
à mes collègues a-t-il une question ou
remarque oui vous n'avez pas répondu à
ma question sur l'inscription de cette
notion de donner sensible ou stratégique
pour la nation dans le texte
les données sensibles déjà il y a des
données sensibles dans le rgpd et
données biométrique les données de santé
les données des mineurs sont qualifiées
de données sensibles méritant une
protection particulière et précisément
la première ministre dans la circulaire
du 31 mai avec une rubrique qui
s'appelle ern9 détail les catégories de
données qui devraient être hébergées par
des systèmes d'informatique en nuage là
aussi je le dis en français parfaitement
sécurisé et les services de la CNIL
auront
en tout cas à coeur de clarifier plus
précisément les règles applicables à un
forcer au riz dans l'hypothèse d'une
décision de l'adéquation qui pourrait
être prise très prochainement par la
Commission européenne sur la question
des transferts de données entre l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis en effet
Matignon a fini par bouger solliciter
constamment par le Parlement sur cette
question très stratégique des données
sensibles on va prendre connaissance
avec les collègues de la circulaire pour
bien regarder en fait qu'il y a dedans
et merci dernier
il a donné sensible et à donner
stratégiques vous avez utilisé les deux
mots c'est pour moi ça va pas tout à
fait les mêmes sujets les données
sensibles comme vous l'avez dit c'est
santé c'est sécurité donner stratégies
que ça peut avoir un lien avec les
données économiques et industrialiser
stratégiques pour notre sécurité
nationale j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller
au bout de ma phrase
bien je vous remercie vraiment pour
votre participation
à notre table ronde qui nous a bien
éclairé mes chers collègues nous nous
trouvons cet après-midi à 15h30 en salle
216 et nous auditionnons le pérenne le
pôle d'expertise et de relax régulation
du numérique je lève la séance il est
11h01